Donald J Trump thank you for joining us
mr. Chuck great to be with you both you
will know that there has been a tragic
shooting today and perhaps yeah two
people killed three people shot on live
TV giving thoughts about that piece of
news well I haven't seen it yet because
I've been in the office all day but I've
been hearing about it and it's just
horrible it's almost got to be at first
it was literally on live television what
a shame what is you won't ask about your
presidential campaign and show you some
vintage footage of Donald Trump from
about two months ago in this building we
talked to you the day after you
announced I want to show you one of the
questions we asked you in your answer
okay what are the odds that Donald Trump
will be the next president United States
I'm running against political people
that do it all their lives I've never
done this before
I don't do this 52018 I would say
anywhere from 10 to 20 percent so then
you said 10 to 20 percent what are the
odds today you're the next president
guys they may be 21 percent no never
like saying it if I have a deal that's
ready to be done literally if I have a
deal and by the way this is double in my
ear I think that is out because it's
about five sounds I hear on that but if
I have a deal that's going to be done
and it's ready to be signed if you say
what I say 50k if it's adds two months
ago you said I mean there Robin what are
these the polls how I'll just just give
us the numbers again straight talk how
many what are your odds on your next
president state let's say maybe 25 or 30
percent 25 or 3 then they don't pretty
low I think it's so if you want to be
concerned if your president want asking
sure if your president won't ask you
about something you'll face President
Obama is facing it this year every
president President Reagan others have
dealt with having to raise the debt
ceiling that's an issue that divides the
Republican Party should Republicans this
later this year agree to raise the debt
ceiling or is there too much of a danger
to the economy if they don't agree to
raise I would like to see them not have
to do it I think there's so much waste
and there's so much actually scandalous
waste in Washington that you shouldn't
have to do it being real but they had
people that knew how to cut and knew how
to make deals with others you know if
you look at what's going on our trade
deficits with all of these countries
that were actually rebuilding we're
rebuilding the world we're rebuilding
China you're looking what's happening
there a lot but short term and maybe
it's going to happen I would not be a
very easy one to do it
so do you think it's worth playing a
game of chicken with President Obama and
not raising the debt ceiling and dealing
with the market and I would say that
it's worth the fight because honestly
there's so much fat in Washington that
have you had the right people in there
you could cut it and you would have no
profit you wouldn't miss a thing just to
clarify you agree with those Republicans
who say don't necessarily raise the debt
ceiling take the risk make President
Obama make a compromise I do okay
there's a lot of fat you can do a lot of
cutting so in recent days you've gotten
some attention for some comments you
made about the hedge fund industry where
you said they were getting away with
murder
because they pay lower taxes on carried
interest hillary clinton has proposed
that you should get rid of that carried
interest loophole and tax carried
interest at the same rate as ordinary
income you agree with her well I'll say
this and and the answer is yes the
carried interest is really a tremendous
burden on the country I have friends
that are make and enemies mostly enemies
frankly otherwise maybe I wouldn't be
saying this but I am saying it for the
good of the country
and none of them are going to support me
and I don't want their support although
I could get it if I wanted and speaking
of that Hillary Clinton has many hedge
fund people and supporting her so in the
end I would say that the hedge fund
people make a lot of money and they pay
very little tax I'm about the middle
class I want the middle class to be
thriving again we're losing our middle
class so change the tax code I would
change it I would simplify it I would
but in this respect you want to tax
carried interest in the same way as
ordinary income his tax I would take
carried interest out and I would let
people that are making hundreds of
millions of dollars a year pay some tax
because right now they're paying very
little tax and I think it's outrageous I
want to lower taxes for the middle class
I want to lower taxes for people that
are making a lot of money that need
incentives that would so that would
affect not just hedge fund people that
would also affect people in limited real
estate partnerships of which you were in
a fair number okay so your proposed your
proposing that you'd like to raise taxes
on yourself I'm okay with okay you know
ready willing and you see my statements
I mean I do very well I don't mind
paying some tax the middle class is
getting clobbered in this country you
know the middle class built this country
not the hedge fund guys but I know
people
in hedge funds they pay almost nothing
and it's ridiculous okay there's a
there's another thing that's for you've
been there's been it's a discussion of
this week there's a story in The New
Yorker magazine that talks about long
story talks about your appeal and talks
about the extent of their wish their
support for you among people who are
members of white supremacist groups at
the same time we've heard this week that
David Duke has come out former leader of
the Grand Dragon Wizard of the Ku Klux
Klan come out and said he's supportive
of your candidacy so my first question
is why do people like that
like Donald Trump and second how do you
feel about the David Duke quasi
endorsement I don't know the answer to
the first who knows why but I don't need
his endorsement I certainly wouldn't
want his endorsement I don't need
anybody's indoors I'm not looking to
repudiate David sure I would do that if
it made you feel better I would
certainly repeat I don't know anything
about him
somebody told me yesterday whoever he is
he did endorse me and actually I don't
think it was an endorsement he said I
was absolutely the best of all the
candidates but if you read this story
and read a lot of people who are white
and we organized white supremacist
groups talking abou Lee about you
talking why they about why they like you
so much without trouble you at all does
that give you pause make you wonder
about your message honestly John I'd
have to read the story a lot of people
like me you know in the poll that just
came out in New Hampshire where I'm a
very high number thirty five percent the
people like me across the board even
Angelico's like me the Democrats like me
liberals like me conservatives like me
absolutely everybody likes and this is
only like there's only a small subset
but but hearing that doesn't make you
worry that there's something in your
message that's striking a chord with the
wrong kind of well I hope there's not I
hope there's not but I haven't read the
story I haven't seen it so the next
debates coming up and one of the things
you said about the first debate was he
got the hardest questions I want to ask
you a question that was asked of a
different candidate and see how you
answer this was asked to Governor Kasich
he said the question was if you had a
son or daughter I'll expand to her
grandchild as well who was gay or
lesbian how would you explain to them
your opposition to same-sex marriage so
don't tell me why is for your position
how would you speak to a child or
grandchild who was gay
well it's the way it is I mean I
wouldn't speak to them at all about it
other than you know they are who they
are and I want them to be happy and I
will love them but I will cherish their
personal opposition to same-sex marriage
if they were you had a gay son daughter
grandchild who said I want to get
married but you don't want it to be
legal how would you know I I thought
actually Governor Kasich is answer was a
very good one he went he's gone to
getting's I've gone to gay weddings I've
been at gay weddings I have been against
from the standpoint of Bible from the
standpoint of my teachings as growing up
and going to Sunday school and going to
church and I've been opposed to it and
we'll just see how it all how it all
comes out but you know if I was ever in
that position I just have to explain it
you mentioned the Bible you've been
talking about how it's your favorite
book and you said I think last night in
Iowa some people are surprised that you
say that I'm wondering what one or two
of your most favored Bible verses are I
wouldn't want to get into it because to
me that's very personal you know when I
talk about the Bible it's very personal
so I don't want to get into it I don't
want to get into it means a lot to you
that you think about or cite the Bible
and means a lot to me but I don't want
to get into specifics
even to cite a verse they don't like I
don't want to do Testament probably
equal I think it's just an incredible
the whole Bible is an incredible I joke
very much so they always hold up the
order that the I say my second favorite
book of all time but I just think the
Bible is just something very special
have you ever read the Quran the view of
that is I have not I have not what's
your view of that as a piece of
important world history well it's
certainly a piece of world history and
lots of things are happening but it's
it's not something that I have a lot of
interest in I would like to find out
what's happening why there's such hatred
why there's I mean you look at what's
going on in the world and it's wonderful
to say hey let's not look at Sweden and
notice that look at Norway and let's not
look at different places but you look at
what's happening with the Quran it's a
pretty scary thing Scott Walker the
other day made
he said there are a handful a moderate
Muslims who were not attracted to the
more jihadist ideologies of terrorists
do you agree with that well I don't I
don't know I'm not sure he knew exactly
what he meant define it well I'm not
sure exactly what he meant either but I
mean that's enough that nobody knew what
only a handful of moderate Muslims you
did you agree with that I think you have
more than a handful of moderate Muslims
but you certainly have a problem with
Muslims and I think he probably misspoke
as Bush would say because every time he
makes a mistake he goes out he says that
he misspoke
I think Scott probably misspoke did he
correct his statement if he later tried
to yeah because you do have much more
than a handful but at the same time we
have problems do we all agree I mean
there are certain problems let me ask
you two historical questions right now
do you believe that Lee Harvey Oswald
acted alone
I believe he acted alone yes you do I
believe he acted no conspiracy for you
no not for me I I think he probably
acted alone who knows but I in my
opinion he acted on my second wife my
second historical question between
Clarence Thomas and Anita Hill who do
you believe in their accounts of that
controversy I really have a lot of
respect I like Clarence Thomas a lot and
I will go with Lawrence Thomas I think
he's really been a very his decisions
are you know in terms of in terms really
of conservative decisions he's probably
about the best there is on the Supreme
Court certainly one of them so you think
I need a hell wide when she said that he
had met I'm not engaged inappropriate no
I just respect Clarence Thomas I don't
know
Anita Hill I'd met Clarence Thomas on a
number of occasions I thought he was
terrific I think he's a terrific person
so what do I know I mean you're asking
me a question like that sort of a crazy
question it was a question that's the
divided the country for a period of time
and over which there still was a lot of
division people take inside I think it
was appointed to the Supreme Court and I
think his decisions have been terrific
decisions from my way of thinking I want
to ask you a couple more historical
things you've wore a Democrat now you're
a Republican
do you recall who you supported in 1992
when it was George Bush Bill Clinton
Russ
I liked I actually liked Ross Perot a
lot I thought he was great and then I
think he went off a little bit off the
deep end unfortunately but I thought he
was good I will say this had he not
existed you don't you're not talking
about Bill Clinton and you're not
worried about Hillary vote right now I
don't know I think I'd probably voted
for Bush actually but I respected Perot
I think Perot really hit something had
he not gone out and come back in and you
know a lot of crazy things happened I
think he probably would have had a
number that was substantially better and
he said probably though so you don't
remember which of those three you're not
clear that I do remember
I don't like to talk about who I voted
for in this case I voted for Bush I
notice they didn't like two below me as
I see about one more in 2000 Gore versus
the other Bush if you remember who you
supported in that election push push
yeah why I was hoping you'd do a good
job okay what didn't you like about well
I don't like what he did with the war I
think what is he like a bad why did you
choose Bush over gore I became more and
more conservative he was certainly more
conservative Ben who wasn't than gore
but Bush was somebody that I was very
disappointed and as you know in 2003 and
2004 I said Iraq is a mistake I'm a
person believed strongly in the military
I would have a very very powerful strong
military that nobody's gonna mess with
us believe me but to do Iraq was a
terrible mistake in my opinion the way
we got out was another mistake also
because I say we should have kept the
oil but these are things that I say and
some people agree and some people agree
strongly and some people don't agree at
all but I was very disappointed with him
but I voted for him earlier today Jeb
Bush someone you've been talking about
he's been talking about you over the
last couple days talked about you and
immigration want to have to look at that
dude is a conservative for crying out
loud I don't think we should spend
hundreds of billions of dollars with an
impractical solution this guy is now the
front-runner he should be held to
account just like me he should be asked
as he was yesterday how are you gonna
pay for it explain how you're gonna stop
all the remittances without violating
people's civil liberties go through
these questions and what you'll find is
this guy doesn't have a plan so one
thing you've been saying about him is
he's low-energy
did he seem low-energy there no achieved
a little bit more dynamic you know you
can't force that and it was a little bit
forced
but how you gonna pay for it we're
spending a hundred and thirty billion
dollars right now on illegal immigration
we are spending a fortune not only the
crime and all the problems that is being
caused but we're spending a minimum of a
hundred and thirty billion dollars
you're gonna pay for it because we're
not going to be spending that kind of
money that's one way we're gonna pay for
one thing that happens in presidential
campaigns as you know as candidates try
to get under each other's skin right you
seem to have gotten under the skin of
some people it's something like that get
under your skin it'll no not at all I
mean it's one of the things that's I'm
not a politician
having been a politician he he's a
person and I guess he's trying very hard
because I used the term low energy
here's a low energy person by nature and
that's okay there's nothing wrong with
that I know some wonderful low energy
people in fact there's some of the
nicest people I know but that doesn't
mean that they're gonna be good at
negotiating with China bringing back our
jobs bringing back our money etc etc
Japan everybody else you look at the
Iran deal I don't know is he gonna make
a much better deal than Barack Obama I
probably tend to doubt it they see the
most likely Republican nominee besides
you at this point I don't know I mean I
see he's way down on the polls and I'm a
little bit surprised I've been hitting
him because I assumed he probably would
be he seems to be like an establishment
guy the last thing we need is another
Bush I feel strongly about that I was
not happy with the last one that I can
tell you read my lips I wasn't happy
with that either so it was a big there
was a big problem read my lips that was
that that was his father who was a
lovely man who I knew who was a lovely
man but the last thing we need is
another bush I would say that maybe if
you would have asked me that question
two three weeks ago maybe at our last
meeting
I would have said maybe he would be the
most likely one now I'm not sure I would
you say it was more likely than this
group of them really the sort of a group
that seems to be forming but so far
they're way behind Jeb Bush recommended
the other day you should read his book
on immigration do you do that anytime
soon no I don't think so
why not because I have other things to
do that I think much more important he
got a little tangled up in this question
about anchor babies rebel what do you
think he's gotten wrong about that well
I read the New York Times editorial
today I mean he took the Hispanics and
all of a sudden he changed Hispanics and
Mexicans with the Asians and now the
Asian community is furious at him and
they're really angry at him I've seen
this protest going on about what he said
so he thought he'd get out of that by
talking about Asians and that was
terrible I know that was that's not
that's not a phrase that you have any
hesitancy about using throughout this
campaign no I'm using it and nobody's
complained about it when I use it they
complain about it because they don't
expect he would be using that he
actually signed a memo saying do not use
anchor babies you know that right he
signed a memo saying don't use anchor
babies don't use the phrase it's not
appropriate and then he uses it
now he uses it because I'm using it and
I think he has to want to maybe he wants
to keep up with it I'm not sure why
maybe he shouldn't be using it I am
going to consider mister running mate I
just don't want to talk about running
mates right now I like to do one thing
that it's like right now I'm looking
good I want to keep looking good I'm not
talking about running this let's talk
about Supreme Court if you're president
that's one of the big responsibilities
our president nominates is is there
somebody you have in mind either a
current or past justices would be kind
of a model for you you know I would have
had had just as Roberts not come out
with that horrible decision on Obama
care which was a disaster he should have
ended Obama care I really like his gait
I really liked his thought process I
liked his background but he is he's not
at all I'm not at all a fan now I would
say very smart great levels of
intelligence great temperament
temperament is very important believe it
or not I have a good temperament some
people say gee his tone is a little bit
tough but I actually have a very good
temperament or you wouldn't be in places
like this you mentioned you've talked
about Carl Icahn and other people you
might want your vision is there someone
out there today who you say isn't on the
court but say this is the kind of person
I would consider for the court I don't
want to mention
I think it's inappropriate to mention
names and certainly at this stage you
know it's so early and wrong way to go
my sister's great I have a sister who's
on the court of appeals and she's
fantastic might be a good Supreme I
notice I think she would be phenomenal I
think she'd be one of the best but
frankly I think she is
we'll have to rule that out there at
least never but I do have a sister who's
very smart and a very good person you've
been and by the way you mentioned call I
can John I just spoke to him yeah and he
said such a big problem corporate
inversion yeah where we have two and a
half trillion dollars sitting outside
can't come in and now what's happening
is companies are leaving this country
you know it used to be you leave New
York for Florida you leave New Jersey
for Texas or something
it used to be state to state now it's
country for country we have companies
with thousands and thousands of jobs
that are leaving this country to go out
and get their look what's the Trump
proposal to handle the question of
inversions let the money come in tax it
at a much lower rate and let the money
come in it's two and a half trillion
dollars we think they don't even know
what it is it could be more than that
and this is money that can be spent in
this country they can't get it in you
know part of the problem with politics
and it's so crazy is that Democrats and
Republicans for two years I've been
hearing about this they always agree and
they still haven't gotten it done
companies are leaving this country in
order to go outside and get their money
so they're taking the money and they're
going to the money and we're losing
thousands and thousands of jobs and by
the way it's getting worse there are so
many big companies looking at going
outside to get that money right now
you've been expressed a lot of concern
about the Chinese currency devaluation
big big concern it's the case when the
currency is devalued that the price of
Chinese goods goes down which means
Americans pay less for the goods that we
buy from China means you also make less
because we're not making our own product
but are you are you against the notion
of lower prices for American consumers
what I'm against is when they devalue
their currency and I've been this has
been a big thing for me for a long time
not only that Japan
Japan is doing the big devaluation in so
with which it's impossible for our
companies to compete the other thing is
if you look at as an example to get off
China for one second you look at Japan
they sell cars
millions and millions of cars to this
country you look at the imbalance
between what we give them and what they
give us tax-free here it's very hard to
get in
when we sell them beef they don't even
want it they fight us as we just got a
minute left you so you announced for
president right down there just over two
months ago does it seem longer than that
it seems longer but it's gone fast
nevertheless it's so happy what's been
the single highlight in the single
low-light 50mm well I think the
low-light was when I attacked was
attacked for the words illegal
immigration and it's turned out to be
maybe also the highlight because now
people are saying you know he was right
you had the horrible story with Kate and
so many people Kate from San Francisco
so many people were were so badly hurt I
mean what's happened is incredible so I
think that was maybe a highlight I think
it was also maybe the word rapist though
that got you in more trouble than
illegal immigrants there's plenty of
that too you have criminals come look
just the other day in California and a
man come over illegal immigrant 66
you're what raped her killed him
sodomized her tortured raped her
I mean you have that too I mean we can
be babies and we can say it doesn't
exist tremendous crime coming and I
think I've done a great service frankly
I hope I have mr. Trump thank you for
having to go